no no don't do it
as for reviewing food fight choking true
sound off black kid smashing
cool-kid
Thank You kid shirts
but hey wait a minute where's batkid
hold it hold it Jason I thought you're
supposed to put on like 50 more pounds
sorry
Lemmy is much chocolate-covered pumpkin
Twinkies as I can - how are we supposed
to have an adventurous 80s boy team
without a fake it well it's a well-paid
Hollywood analyst I am technically of a
sizeable girth oh I'm sorry did you want
to be known as the fattest well
according to the chart no did you at
least bring the adorable pet mascot well
gang I think our first meeting of the
token truth has just begun
if there's anything the ATS have taught
us if that boys rule yeah
molecular whatever from stand by me to
Goonies to explorers and of course the
all-time best new holiday classic
Monster Squad that film imagine all the
classic Halloween monsters in modern day
eighties and the only ones that can stop
them are a group of smoking swearing
perverted little adolescents that
clearly don't give a shit that they've
considered a family film or not there's
no doubt about it it takes major nars
and in honor of this awesomeness we put
together our own 80 squad of boy tropes
is that a right guys yeah now if you'll
excuse me I'm gonna start this review
you why are you because I'm the charming
awkward shy main character with a heart
of gold that gets the most focus but
we're like a million times more
interesting than you and that's why
you'll sell more toys but we still need
to keep the focus on the Wonder Bread
protagonist me statistically this seems
the most illogical as the eighties in a
nutshell this is monster squad yes we
start off in a 70s horror exploitation
film where Count Dracula or party city's
interpretation of Count Dracula is seen
walking by some of the scariest effects
you'll see outside of a Chucky Cheese
but the townspeople are pissed off at
the vampires for all the possums they've
been eating and they summon a portal to
suck them into limbo but unfortunately
the wrong people gets sucked in
cut two years later was something even
scarier is going on American education
we kind of have this monster Club okay
we draw those pictures to put on our
Clubhouse walls you draw pictures during
mrs. Carlson's science class when you're
supposed to be paying attention this is
back before schools have real problems
drawing in the classroom oh no put
Billy's gun and drug possession on hold
but these two little children were
drawing drawing science is real monsters
are not we don't know that sir this is
Shawn a young boy who's obsessed with
anything horror related as you can
clearly tell by his t-shirt Stephen King
rules
don't patronize me kid I spent most of
last review listing Stephen King's rules
you learn to love them after the first
40 books he's joined by his friends
Patrick and fat kid yes no I mean they
literally have a character called fat
kid in this listen it's like they're not
even trying to hide what characterize
pawns they are they just trade out
address them as their physical trope
that said yeah well get back - munching
fabulous but he's not the only one who's
tight casted look it's the bully from
Wonder Years playing the exact same
bully it's at the wearing a hair plant
for some reason good evening ladies and
gentlemen and welcome to our show
tonight's question what makes bet get
back back it down here EJ get out of
here you know not a good answer to make
any sense let's go to our man on the
street Derek hi I'm Derek and I'm the
street where fat kid is walking track
Wow are they looking to take this act on
the road as boys go they've worked a
long time on this routine
oh shit it's Lindsay Lohan beam in my
friend Horace Rudy I'm gonna nurture
this moment of pain for you
dropped your candy bar EJ it's his it's
yours now
E yeah well wait until you see what he's
like when the cameras aren't rolling I
always this is Rudy a badass kid who for
some reason really wants to join Sean's
monster Club that he put together he's
in junior high we should let him in a
one condition
monster test his Frankenstein the name
of the monster but the guy who made him
the guy right wait am I in or what yeah
it's a little questioning why Rudy would
want to hang with them seeing how he's
older and clearly has other things on
his mind I'm beginning to like this club
look I may have killed a homeless person
and need a really good alibi your club
is a good cover okay that's
discrimination turquoi yeah that'll
teach those lousy girls we're not
indulging our prejudice dudes can't I be
a part of your collective midlife crises
I'm sorry Tamara but as you can read no
girls the backward S is for emphasis
yeah you'll just piss up our boys club
with flowers or something yeah you guys
aren't even boys most of you are in your
fucking 30s don't worry we'll only
ignore you till the third act but will
suddenly realize the error of our ways
well that's like two-thirds of the
review I'll teach you from maturing
faster than us
but seriously if you could come and say
but in the last third you worthless sack
of nothing just that me great girl suck
dracula literally ships himself via
airmail to the boys neighborhood but
through a pretty awesome reveal seen the
cargo is dropped and he sets out to
locate the rest of his team
whoa sorry just a little tweet check out
there we all get nervous twitches like
that sometimes maybe you can go see
Groundhog Day part 12 tonight only for
thinking with you is it please Shawn it
is a guy with an axe Groundhog Day 12
about a killer with an axe
boy I know Bill Murray's been really
loose with some of his roles but this is
actually kind of awesome never mind you
telling me there was this 2,000 year old
mummy here right the father is a cop who
gets called to a crime scene where
apparently an ancient mummy has been
stolen but don't worry
his comedic sidekick is there too Chris
Tucker it up you want ask me about the
phone what about the hood or I thought
you'd never ask you know that be firemen
steady
he's like a primordial Gus from psych
you wanna hate what a stereotype he is
but he's just so damn good at being that
stereotype the problem is two
thousand-year-old dead guys do not get
up and walk away by themselves never
mind me I'm just a 2000 year old dead
guy fulfilling a punch line we also get
a glimpse of our werewolf looks more
like a we're badger a shit face we're
badger as him and the other monsters
meet up to bring the Frankenstein
monster back to life huh the same way
you jump start a car apparently
give him more gas no no you're flooding
him oh good
where am I gonna find the resurrection
chapters time of night
wonderful now that they've awkwardly
held their hands out without actually
grabbing them they can finally start
their recreation of the Halloween that
almost wasn't
all hail jodhpurs but Shawn gets a
feeling that something is up for you see
his mother got him a book from a garage
sale that's get this van helsings
vampire diary and somebody named mr.
Alucard is looking for it yeah I don't
know what's funnier the fact that
Dracula the king of all vampires uses
such an obvious anagram to trick people
or the fact that it actually takes the
kid to tries to figure out that it was
Dracula backwards I would say he needs
to pay more attention in school but they
said he does nothing but drop pictures
of monsters but you'd think this would
be kind of second nature to him if he's
such a dork
but he's not the only one getting
ghostly visions one of the other members
of the club gets a creepy visit can you
help me outside of this obvious joke I
have no reason to be in this same thing
listen keep this up and you're not gonna
look at those monster magazines
why don't you watch something less
violent like Robotech Shawn declares his
group the monster squad as he's
convinced that there are in fact
monsters roaming the neighborhood I
think there's monsters like real ones
The Mummy disappeared from the museum
tonight mommy came in my house we don't
want to hear how your mommy came in your
house
weird Confederate hat wearing kid wait a
minute what yeah he wears a Confederate
hat through like most of this movie was
this a thing in the eighties well the
kids tried to see if they can head the
van Helsing diary translated by some
scary German guy and I'm not even
kidding that's also his name in the
movie here a German guy scary sure
this movie is so bizarrely blunt one of
the monsters makes himself present at
the pond next to Sean's little sister I
hope you have your flood insurance paid
up kid this usually doesn't end well
boys time is almost up it's your last
chance for pie shall I critically serve
your other desserts good and evil are in
constant flux so he translates the book
saying then amulet of good it's what's
keeping balance in the world it is a
talisman which Ward's off evil and is
how you say in this table that means it
can't be destroyed I speak German hear
us to battle those forces himself but he
also says it's made vulnerable every
hundred years and if it's destroyed evil
will rule the world well seeing how it's
almost a hundred years a clock they
figure that's what the monsters are
after you should know a lot about
monsters now that you mention it I
suppose I do
holy shit movie you want to grow these
viewers up as quickly as possible
I suppose I do mmm I'm just gonna slip
my innocent mind into denial mode and
say that somebody's phone number he's
trying to remember I don't think that's
enough number somebody's phone number
okay so say what gets Amite then what we
get a virgin then what
well our virgin takes the amulet reads
the magic stuff in the book and blammo
we blow home in limbo Christ I can't
believe how many non kid things are in
this obvious kids movie hell this was
almost looking like a Pepsi commercial
before that line came up unless maybe
that's what Pepsi wants to be associated
with Pepsi know any virgins but in the
middle of their virgin search Shaun's
little sister comes across something
truly interesting
damn even the little sisters got a mouth
on her how are we teaching on Sesame
Street nowadays today's episode is
brought to you by fucking chicken shit
eating mother ha bastard
yeah I guess the universal monster films
were kind of disturbingly accurate kind
of a strange coincidence
does that mean somewhere there's a
family the Opera that can actually sing
well some corporations slap their logo
on that that is by far the most perfect
ending to a commercial if ever I've seen
one happy Halloween to you and your
family brought to you by Pepsi know any
virgins so she did help them out didn't
she
yeah feel bad about how we treat Tamara
earlier yeah
bogus balls you should have been more
supportive like the great Robert II lean
that looks booth hey I have an idea how
about the Mex girl we see we let her
join which according to my calculations
should be just about oh how did
gentlemen I was just peeing standing up
and I saw that you had a boys club sorry
buddy but it's a bit of a sausage fest
in here and we're in need of a few
clamps besides you look like Yankee
anyways no damn it
I can't believe my calculations were
wrong he was pretty hot though
touken troupe will return after these
messages
now return to the token truth so the
masters find the amulet presumably while
of full moons been going on the entire
week and victory seems to be theirs well
his performance was so hammy it actually
woke me up so they prepare for monster
hunting via motivational synth guitar
and ask Patrick's sister who Rudy's been
eavesdropping on this whole time to help
them seeing how they're pretty sure
she's a virgin
which is really confusing seeing how
they never mentioned the virgin had to
be female but in an eighties Boys movie
girls are either annoying nuisances or
walking sex there's no one between you
guys are sick guess what there's a space
on the bulletin board right between the
prom committee notes and the football
rust oh my God he's been taking pictures
of her changing doesn't technically mean
she should be blackmailing him I mean
that's kind of serious shit you can be
put away for stuff like that unless you
plan to put it online in which case
suddenly nobody can find you I don't
believe this they figure they're at 666
shadow Brook Road because I think we've
established this is not a very subtle
Dracula and they interrupt him trying to
break down the wall
the children's cover is literally blown
which of course leads to the line that
would define a generation for every
young lover of monster movies this blue
every kid's mind wolfmann has nerds this
movie is asking questions who never
would have thought to ask before
Frankenstein's monster is made up of
several different people does that mean
they've had several different neurons if
every part of the mummy is wrapped up
did they wrap up is nards as well did
The Creature from the Black Lagoon have
hidden arts nerds that retreat inward
like a turtle if the Phantom of the
Opera space is deformed does he also
have deform darts this movie is asking
questions questions and neat popping
answers who dare interrupt us something
odd conversation what we're talking
nards there's a monster out here look
buddy I know you want to join our team
but I don't know what's real anymore
look I barely just got away check it out
oh god it's the greatest threat to a
tease boys team that there is
Frankenstein the Wolfman Norris horse
it's
realities well too bad
insurance house rent extruder
we have to utilize everybody that we can
by calling the authorities we can't do
that so take us away and perform science
experiments on us damn Union bastards
according to my charts there should be
an ancient book of ancientness every 80s
kids room has an ancient book of ancient
nests you're right red sauce test
tubular aah
according to this there is one way out
what is it an 80s montage
ready now Ethel
listen y'all get sell a minute with the
music do something else
according to my calculations there's a
really simple way around this
understanding your science mumbo-jumbo
me and speak English but simply we lock
the door so after the Boise escaped with
the amulet by using garlic on pizza
because it's the 80s and pizza solve
everything they ride off in their car
but Dracula's hers ain't far behind
that your car you're destroying I don't
know what place rents hearses with
skulls on the hood but I imagine they're
pretty closely the father corners him at
gunpoint but Dracula uses every vampires
classic deadliest method dynamite um I
kind of thought that was Wiley coyotes
weapon of choice but hell if the
Headless Horseman can use a machine gun
nowadays I guess anything's possible
hey don't do that my black guy is still
in there Jesus Christ you killed an
eighties white cops comedic black
sidekick he's practically naked
throughout the rest of the movie without
him
honey why is the try voicemail late for
any black guy holy nartz
the kids try to get this sister to read
the book but some of Dracula's fresh
bites start tracking them down very very
slowly
be careful at this rate they'll catch up
with you in about an hour the other
monsters catch up to them but once again
dynamite seems to be the answer to
everything in this film this movie that
only gave us an exploding werewolf it
gave us an exploding mid-air werewolf a
midair wolf if you will that's two extra
points for creative exploitation but
unfortunately we're badger don't give a
shit where badger just puts it so back
together again it doesn't bode well
seeing how the sister is apparently not
a virgin that leaves only the majority
of our main characters that can do it
curse these wolves we forgot to insert
dude did you find something about this
movie you didn't like yeah I don't know
just the more I think about it it
doesn't make a whole lot of logical
sense
yeah scientifically speaking nothing's
really coming together yeah it's like
reality said
let's keep going I guess Wacka Wacka we
see by pretty fucking huge coincidence
fat kid comes across the bully from
earlier who won't let him in trying to
escape a monster my name is Horace I
should be blown away by how incredibly
awesome this moment is how every kid
probably cream their pants at this thing
well all I can think about is how
inappropriate it is for a child to be
holding a shotgun did anybody look at
the charts what their parents have
flipped out over this movie Dianetics to
figure out that Sean's sister as well as
anyone really can read the passage but
of course because all vampires are anti
running Dracula heads over very very
slowly to stop them that's for Dracula
unborn that's for Dracula dead and
loving it
that's public Trinity I mean Adam
Sandler was a better leader ee for sale
this is for the ridiculous haircut and
Gary Oldman it looks like in a final for
crying out loud
gives me the amulet you bitch I'm
exploiting this pg-13 rating like nobody
shit ask goddamn bitch business but
Frankenstein's monster comes in to
catchphrase it to death the portal is
finally opened and Van Helsing comes out
to finish his job thanks for doing all
the hard work for me
please don't let Steven summers tell my
story but it looks like the Frankenstein
monster has to go too which is actually
pretty fucking sad
oh for God's sake really really he
catches the bear yeah they'll keep you a
great company if Dracula doesn't take it
away from you and piss down its button
remove ties I'm sure it'll make all the
difference eventually the military comes
in yeah wonder how that call went
general half of Spencer's clearance
costumes are running amok and they tried
to figure out what happened alright son
where are they where are the monsters in
my house
will you stop putting the camera on him
can somebody tell me what the Sam Hill
is going on around here well we can sir
who are you we're the monster squad plus
they say the catchphrase that no one
will ever repeat plays a song that
nobody will ever buy and we finished the
movie that I'm sure in no way we'll ever
be dated what so ever so guys what do
you think well when you really think
about it it's pretty stupid yeah
really stupid like it's amazing the 80s
even allowed it out of its own decades
stupid numbers agree know what audience
this is aimed for I mean it has aspects
of a kid's film a lot of famous overuse
aspects but there's way too much
swearing and gore and violence and sex
and just all-around bad messages and
gunplay yeah right what about that scene
where Dracula calls a little girl a
bitch right to her face it was very me
all right buddy you may be a reality
monster but I know the one thing that
destroys reality
Internet comments Ebola is the biggest
threat in America which live is the
world's smartest man little Walker was
just a plot by radical samurai pizza
cats the effects are great except when
they're not it's just a huge mess it's
overly violent it's insane it's totally
just in the eighties and that's why it's
awesome
this movie it's over the violent it's
insane it's totally drenched in the
eighties and look at all the gunplay and
this seems a little girl being called a
bitch to her face I think again
mayonnaise is everywhere it's like it's
ringing to everything that would look
ridiculous and awesome about one of the
most ridiculously awesome time periods
ever if you love the 80s and you a
monster fill that this is the best new
Halloween classic god fucking damn it I
wonder who that is
I defeated the monster can I be in your
stupid game now
well we done for us recently I defeated
the monster I don't see any proof I got
a new laptop I already got one
i crossdress Oh every by crossdressers
on this dinosaur critic which by the way
we need to get your dress size you know
what that's fine
I'm gonna go audition to be a 90 sports
team tomboy I'm sure she'll be
fantastically written well I believe
proper protocol calls for us turning to
the camera saying our group name some
terrible pop song plays and then the
credits very slowly rolled by while we
just linger here awkwardly tubular
affirmative couch younga the cell will
rise again well without further ado with
token show
you